welcome to this video playing parallax
from the US yeah sloth know the Queens
gambit declined you see this laugh more
often nowadays okay all rights playing a
very early successes usually welcome
sight this kind of position is just
quite comfortable for white yeah age 32
give me this little we treat square
there okay he's absolutely not trying to
play play any of his standard advance
the cs black now he might go for beef i
now let's let's just play c5 and trying
to fix this weakness I'm also ready to
play a form at the right moment opening
up the whole thing if he plays b6 I have
a nice target on the C file normal
looking move would be probably and maybe
97 here to prepare ye five but I will
play before then yeah come on if not not
allowing black to just play five here
yeah I'm giving up the d5 square
possibly for one of his nights to go
there but I have much more space and
that should be really nice why is he not
taking if he allows 'if I've he might as
well wow I can also just take here and
take g64 pawn okay
that looks really really awkward
especially considering that it's not
just a pawn the the whole light squares
go down the drain okay I can take a d5
here that shouldn't be too bad if he
takes ed for this Bishop c7 trapping the
Queen that's that's good yep here we go
that's the Queen there was a disaster oh
it's not the Queen itch but it should be
the queen right if I go 95 how what kind
of squares does he have he has said yes
you can take the bishop other night okay
then take with them on black resigned
yeah well this this is opening line with
c6 is not a really good idea if you want
to play without c5 what you can do then
then you should really play the line
that everybody plays nowadays this this
kind of thing and then prepare c5 later
putting a plane with c6 it's not really
a great idea you should only put it on
c6 when white is committed to c5 already
for example if we look at this castle to
e3 night BB 75 here black can play c6 as
he will play b 6 a-5 later to open up
the Queen side and maybe ultimately
later switch to an e5 plant if
everything works out well but he
committed very early to the to the c6
move and with rookie one it's very
difficult for black to get in 'if i
foresee hive now and he went into a very
impressive setup and then a 65 year he
it gets really really tricky this is the
move i expected
and knowing you for yeah but here well
he just has to sit and wait him now
there is nothing much she can do maybe I
know something something like that and
then just sit and wait why this of
course having much more space very nice
position or what i said in the game he
can decide to take off course which is
better for white but anyway he can he
can try that he has an interesting
interesting moment how should white play
here i think i would have probably done
that the bishop that is really annoying
and cannot easily be attacked even yeah
here white is better I'm controlling the
e5 break and this Bishop 1c8 is a very
very sorry piece yeah it's a fairly
typical position for Queens gambit
declined that went wrong as black has
not solved his principal problem the c8
p.m. okay well thanks for watching